here are five more signs and symptoms
that you may be experiencing a true
emergent situation and should get to the
hospital immediately you hear it all the
time only go to the emergency room if
it's a true emergency but how does one
know if it's a true emergency situation
maybe your symptoms are a little all
over the place or you're just not sure
my name is Dr Jordan Wagner I'm a
board-certified emergency medicine
physician with a YouTube channel called
Dr ER and of course if you think you are
experiencing a true emergency please
call 9-1-1 or your country's emergency
equivalent and or get to the hospital
immediately number five reason you
should head to the ER fainting or
dizziness fainting is when you suddenly
lose Consciousness for a short period of
time you're talking for example doing
something and then boom the lights just
go out and maybe you fall onto the floor
this is usually caused by a sudden drop
in blood flow to your brain passing out
or painting can be caused by many
different things pain being overheated
the sight of blood anxiety lots of
different causes but if a person you
know faints in front of you lay them
down on the ground definitely don't get
them up to quickly because this could
cause a person to faint again remember
it's that sudden of blood pressure
change so stay low to the ground to
avoid further injury also make sure you
call your doctor or head to the hospital
because medically we need to investigate
whether or not there is a more serious
underlying medical issue going on that
is causing the fainting episodes number
four reason to get
the reason you need to get to the
hospital this also goes for symptoms
like coughing or vomiting blood blood
into urine bloody diarrhea or your
pregnant and experiencing bleeding or
you have any other abnormal bleeding
that you are concerned about that is a
definite reason for you to come to the
emergency department besides an obvious
trauma that comes with its own set of
possible complications and risks there
are so many reasons why a person could
potentially be bleeding and none of them
have any good outcomes if the blood loss
is in stock also keep in mind that A
good rule of thumb is if you are trying
to stop the bleeding and wrapping it
just doesn't get the job done place a
finger or two straight onto the area and
apply firm pressure there are so many
reasons why a person could potentially
be bleeding and none of them have any
good outcomes if the blood loss isn't
stopped nevertheless if severe
hemorrhaging isn't stopped a person
could bleed to death in a short when of
time number three abdominal pain
especially intense localized paint this
is the single leading reason why people
come to the emergency department
actually about 12 million annual ER
visits in the U.S each and every year
for abdominal pain but just because a
person has stomach pain doesn't always
mean the underlying issue is actually a
stomach problem your abdomen houses many
other organs which could be causing the
pain your intestines pancreas liver
kidneys appendix or kidney stones did
your appendix just burst I mean the list
goes on and on for possible reasons your
stomach could be upset or in pain if you
have constant or severe abdominal pain
or any pain paired with a fever or if
you have changes in pain intensity or
location for instance does the pain go
from adult pain to a sharp stabbing pain
or does your pain radiate to another
area also increasing pain in a very
specific spot is worthy of an ER visit
as well I'll give you some examples if
the regular quadrant of your abdomen
hurts that usually indicates
appendicitis which needs to be seen in
the hospital immediately left lower side
of the abdomen that usually could
indicate diverticulitis or some issue or
infection with the colon any specific
area or any pain accompanied by another
symptom difficulty breathing fever or
changes in behavior of the pain get to
the hospital step number two intense
fever first let's define what a fever is
a body temperature of over 100.4 degrees
Fahrenheit or 38 degrees Celsius is
considered a fever and often a sign of
infection in the body if a child is
under the age of three months and
experiencing any elevated temperature
call your health care provider or head
to the ER immediately for anyone older
than an infant typically patients are
told to come to the hospital when a
fever is hitting or heading towards the
103 degree Fahrenheit or 39.4 degrees
Celsius Mark any higher body
temperatures than that definitely come
to the emergency department number one
confusion or or changes in mental status
if a person is not acting or thinking
like they normally would if a person
suddenly confused disoriented possibly
agitated or even having suicidal
thoughts you should immediately seek
medical attention for any abrupt change
in a person's mental status several
serious medical conditions or even
outside factors can cause changes in a
seemingly healthy person and this is
definitely cause for concern serious
medical conditions like Strokes
infections like meningitis brain injury
low oxygen levels medication side
effects psychological issues or even
drug or substance intoxication so if you
see any sort of acute confusion or
sudden mental changes in a person you
care about definitely seek out immediate
emergency treatment because it could be
a matter of life or death alright that's
been a quick breakdown of some more
signs you should go to the ER and if you
missed it check out part one of this
video where I go into even more signs
and symptoms of when you should head
into the hospital also let me know in
the comments if you've ever made a trip
to the emergency department and what
that experience was like for you we can
learn a lot by learning from each
other's past medical experiences so
definitely leave me a comment below and
shout out to nucleus medical media for
their awesome video library and Graphics
this video was a collaboration between
them and as always make sure you
subscribe to both channels thank you so
much for watching and stay healthy my
friends